[Music]
[Applause]
when's the last time we had tim kirkchin
on
i would guess 2016
with the cubs checking my records why
has he been avoided that's a travesty
that's way too long
why is he avoiding us it could be on us
let's bring in
tim kirk tim kirkchen espn
hi timmy how are you i'm good dad i have
not been avoiding you
why would i do that i used to be on your
show every friday it was great
yeah you know what i'm going to blame
fritzy for that prince
why haven't you had tim kirk and i it is
a major oversight i love timmy and i
have no excuse for that
but fritzy's always going let's get
verducci on
and i know and rosenthal and i said wow
what about kirchon
i did say buster can't do it today so
what about tim
we were okay with her it's great to have
you on tim uh great to talk to you again
and uh you know we were talking about
this with the
strikeouts when we were growing up if
you struck out 100 times as a hitter
that was embarrassing now it's okay
at what point did it did we change where
it's okay to strike out
in baseball uh for me dan it came in the
mid-80s
when bo jackson jim presley rob dear
pete and cabelia they all came to the
big leagues at the same time
big strong guys swung as hard as they
could at 25
30 homers a year struck out 150 times
and ever since then it has been
okay decay that's about 35 years but
the last 5 to 10 years this is
completely
out of control now 1092
more strikeouts in april than there were
hits
it is ridiculous you talk about a
hundred strikeout guys dan from 1900
to 1963 combined
there were 94 individual players
who struck out 100 times and now every
year
we have 160 guys or so who strike out
a hundred times or more it's amazing
what we're watching these days
and it's mostly because the stuff these
guys see
on a nightly basis is ridiculously
good the velocity is so far off the
charts and yet
it's the secondary stuff that's even
better than the velocity
and it comes down to this when jacob
degrom max scherzer garrett cole are
dealing and they're locating our hitters
have
no chance against them they don't just
make an out they strike out
it's remarkable what we're watching
every night now
but also and i know it's i'm the get off
my lawn guy but put the ball in play
like put put your bat on the ball and
you don't see that
and this is what i miss with baseball it
it's it's subtle
but it is the hit and run a stolen base
uh hitting it the other way oh there's a
shift on oh my gosh
uh how about you just hit it where
there's nobody over there
so like can you see somebody
embracing what whitey herzog had with
the cardinals
where it's going to be speed and defense
and running like something that's
counter intuitive to what we have will
we have a team that does that
no dan we won't that cardinal team was
built
for doing that they played on astroturf
they had a bunch of really fast guys
they beat the ball into the ground and
outran everybody
we don't play that game anymore dan i
did the game last night ravi eduardo
prez and i and we had
two bunts for a hit and we had two
sacrifice bunts last night
and one was a squeeze and i almost
started five
i was so happy to see that because we
don't
play that game anymore i mean look at
look at the yankees i'm doing the yankee
game tonight
with ravi and eduardo the yankees don't
have a triple yet
they have seven stolen bases all season
which is a lot for them but it's the
fewest in the league and they average
about
one double per game this is where we are
if you don't hit the ball out of the
ballpark as
most teams do you simply don't
win these days and i desperately miss
growing up at a time where rod guru
would dump a bun and get a hit
brett butler would drag one to the right
side and get a hit
and we don't have that anymore and i
miss it
because i think those are the most
skillful exciting parts of the game
and i think we're all a little bit tired
of just watching guys hit it
as far as they can and striking out
three times in between
i was also wondering about the pitching
stats here we've had four no-hitters
already this season
if if it's a swing and miss league and
nobody's putting the ball in play
then we're probably going to break the
single season no hit
record i'm i'm going to guess we should
be flirting with it right
well eight is the record that was done
in the 1800s but dan you're right
we have lost the value of the hit
in the game today we're no longer
interested nor
are our hitters being taught to hit a
hard ground ball through that hole over
there
they're not interested in getting a
single last year dan
the reds who made the playoffs had more
walks
than singles it's the first time in
history any team is finished
with more walks than singles that's
where we are now but
i'm gonna try to defend our hitters
because i'm with you on this can we
please just put it in play
can we please beat the shift over there
but our guys have been swinging the same
way
for 15 years they have one swing and
it's beautiful and if you run into that
bad path it's not a line or the left
it's a home run
to ask these guys who have been hitting
the same way for 15 years okay we're
gonna make a big change tonight
we want you to choke up and hit it to
right field and we want you to do it
against max scherzer tonight
good luck with that it's like telling a
basketball player you know the way
you've been shooting for all these years
we want you to change your shooting
motion tonight and we want you to
not follow the flight of the ball a lot
of guys still do that that's a hard
thing to do
so i think to ask a hitter hey we want
you to make a change and we want you to
go out
and get a hit off of justin bieber well
good luck with that so that's the
concern is
this is a this is going to take years to
make the change
and we're going to have to literally go
to batting cages where 10 year olds are
hitting and tell them
all right this is what we want you to do
we want you to hit it over there
and we don't want you to try to get it
up in the air every single time
you just called shane bieber justin
bieber
i did not did i really and i wouldn't
know justin bieber if i fell over
oh god i'm sorry what happened to you
this is why we don't have tim kirkchin
on todd justin bieber what is that all
about
[Laughter]
i'm sorry that that's terrible you know
what we'll take it out of the rear okay
so don't don't worry about that we'll
clean it up
well i i don't know anything about music
and i just found out the other day that
chris martin is the lead singer
in coldplay i wouldn't know one of their
songs if
they hit me over the head either so
anything that is
uh pop culture wise just leave me out
what's the last concert you attended
well i've only been to three in my whole
life and i'm 64 years old i went to see
dan fogelberg in college on a date that
was a disaster by the way
then wait why was it a disaster well
me and a woman in in college i had no
idea what to do
that's why it was a disaster and by the
way that still goes today so you were
striking out bef
at the rate of today's baseball players
uh way worse than today's race yes
um i didn't even try you didn't have a
launch angle did you
right and then my daughter my daughter
in the eighth grade
we went to see yellow card which i kept
getting mixed up i kept calling them a
green
card because i get i i could piss them
up with green day or something
and stupid me having been to one concert
in my life i was told
concert starts at 7 30. so i have five
eighth grade girls in my car
and i think all right concert starts at
7 30. we'll be done by nine
home by ten it'll be great they had like
four bands play before
yellow card or green card or whatever
they were called
and we went they went on at 10 30. we
got home at like
1 30 in the morning on a school night
the women were like ready to kill me it
was so bad
and then i saw kenny chesney at syracuse
when we dropped our daughter
off for college about 10 years ago so
i'm 64 and i've been to three concerts
in my life
and i just found out the other day molly
hatchet is not a woman
someone should have told me that before
this
how are the dodgers do you start when do
you start to worry if you're a dodger
fan here tim
well they've lost 15 out of 20 and
during that stretch
only the tigers have played worse than
the dodgers who knew this is the
ultimate beauty of the game dan the
warriors and their great days never
never had a 5 and 15 stretch where you
wondered are they okay
the dodgers are going to be fine they
got a bunch of injuries they haven't hit
in two weeks
it's gonna change they're gonna be the
best team in baseball by the end of the
year but it just shows you when
people ask me when the season started
will the dodgers win 117 games this year
i said no it's too hard to do that in
today's game
so this is a bad rough patch for them
they'll get out of it they'll be great
before long
do you still play basketball
yeah i played the other day
this was so bad i was at a gym and i was
just shooting by myself
and these two kids came up to me there
was another like old guy in there
shooting at another hoop the two little
kids probably 10 years old said
do you guys want to play two on two so i
assumed
the two old guys would pair up and we'd
have a little you know a young guy and
an old guy instead
the two little guys wanted to play the
two old guys
two on two so that was the last time
that i played and i
i took that 10 year old to the rack
believe me
i was pretty proud of him because he was
bigger than i was so
now you used to play hoops with cal
ripken
right yes how good was rip you know
amazing
danny never played in high school and he
became a
great basketball player i mean he's so
big and so strong
around the rim you just cannot move him
with those giant legs
in the lane so if i may this is terrible
i should never say this he asked me once
he said
show me how to do that move that you do
okay and it's a little guy move that if
i can't make that play
i can't play anywhere all right so i
show it to him and it took me like a
year to perfect that move for me
so i showed it to him and then we played
like three days later
and he's using that move in the game
three days it took him
but you know what he did you know what
he did he practiced that he went into
the gym by himself
and worked on this little shake with his
left hand and then crossed to his right
the move i showed him he had it in three
days it took me
it took me a year he had it in three
days that's how great an athlete he is
see this is why we have tim kirchen on i
love tube cartoon i don't understand how
this happened
way too long for dude she doesn't have
stories like this you're right that was
that's my bad i
got confused now rosenthal does but
verducci does not
rosenthal always has a bad phone line
anyway oh have a story yeah
uh tim it's great to talk to you about
you always you put a smile on my face i
know you love the game
uh i'd like to love the game more let's
put it that way and they make it hard
sometimes
yeah well we're getting back to it dan
don't worry but thanks for having me on
today it's really nice to see you
great to see you timmy that's uh tim
kirchen tim kirchen espn
and uh he's got the game tonight the
yankees and the rays
prepping for tonight's game